looks like Jojo Fletcher and Jordan  Rogers are staying strong the rumors um  they've been terrible the bachelorette  couple has dealt with some drama in  recent weeks after Jordans ex Brittney  Farrar tried to back up her cheating  allegations with a lengthy social media  post it's hard it was I mean to be  honest it was really hard  Jojo instagrams a close-up shot of the  two holding hands with her massive  engagement ring on full display she  captioned the snap quote the best thing  to hold on to in life is each other and  tacos it's us now do you mean us and the  former NFL star shared this photo of the  sweet fiancees getting cozy on the couch  and wrote always holding on to my best  friend but where are these tacos you  speak of joy Fletcher I can multitask  you